so let me introduce the panelists Phil
broader Phil going to come on up like an
ounce what you do Phil is a venture
capitalist like I am I probably do it a
lot better than I do Phil Phil may not
know this when I mentioned the first
company and his role he serves as a
director of several companies including
approve oh you know I'm I was the lead
investor versa believe me we'll talk
about okay so I'm the lead investor of a
company that competed I mean we were we
were pretty vehement you had a great CEO
and and and and so we had fun in this
space which basically it provides
continuous IT and financial controls
started by the sarbanes-oxley
regulations he's a he's involved in in
grid and home security net Cordia a
network software company before coming
to his venture capital firm which is
Novak Biddle in 1999 he was a high-tech
management consultant with Mackenzie the
other management consulting company
other than Booz Allen didn't really fly
did it Booz Allen has Allen employees
like 12,000 people in the in the in
nation scale how many of you work for
Booz Allen you got to be look at this
look how many you work for mackynzie
come on come on so welcome Phil yeah
Eric Tyler come on up Eric serves as
president and CEO of why tricity I had
to twist Eric's arm to come here tonight
I wouldn't have laughed at that joke
either he is a really interesting story
about how he how he injured his arm
really interesting but we won't get it
because it but I with the hell traveling
on a motorcycle across Australia is that
in most alone is that the most unique
kind of get away you've ever heard about
he's got all the way he made it halfway
before the bike he crashed the bike and
himself some CEO of
why tricity the he and his team are
working to develop scuze me my phone's
ringing are working to develop wireless
electricity that will operate safely and
efficiency over distance to several
meters this is particularly interesting
to me I'm involved in two vehicle
companies developing two vehicles one is
an EV and and and literally his work is
going to go into some pretty interesting
places pretty obviously drive into a
garage without plugging in charge your
car just do it wirelessly but other
places like you were explaining down
hole in oil and gas but places that you
just don't want to run wires to not safe
not convenient not economic so so I'll
just skip the rest of all this is I got
what you okay pradeep khosla i'll try to
avoid any ribbing of you for deep but
he's just an easy target for deep was
appointed dean of carnegie mellon's
college of engineering in 2004 since
then he has done a tremendous job
bringing the college of new heights he's
also the Phillips and Marsha Dowd
university professor and has served in
many other leadership roles at Carnegie
Mellon including founding director of
Carnegie Mellon Scilab and Institute for
complex engineering systems ahead of the
electrical and I don't want to eat guess
we don't need all that stuff he does a
lot of important stuff right does a lot
of important stuff priya Narasimha
nuttin I get it right yeah associate
professor of Carnegie Mellon's
electrical and engineering department as
well as director of the Scilab mobility
Research Center at CMU her innovative
career has been recognized with a
National Science Foundation career award
a sloan fellowship and IBM faculty
partnership awards she has also been
recognized for teaching with the College
of Engineering's Benjamin Richard tier
Teaching Award in addition to yen scam
the technology allows sporting event
fans to actually see a replay instant
replays kind of right from their seats
her
research projects include trinette row
which aims to develop cost-effective
smartphones enabled with the system
technologies for visually impaired
people I love the I bird thing okay so
this is this was intriguing so were you
like one of the developers of I bird is
that so I burped Pittsburgh this is I
Berg we you know in Silicon Valley or
famous for putting an eye in front of
everything so the zyburg and it's for
somebody who grew up in Pittsburgh this
is basically a mobile app for ego vermin
where you can actually take pictures of
potholes and and allow the government to
see it to basically resolve it quicker
so whether it's pothole or graffiti or
anything the government cares about but
can you imagine how many it's the only
way to resolve pothole situation of
Pittsburghers have everybody you know
take a picture of a pothole so I think
it's really so innovation doesn't stop
innovation hits every facet of our life
so so what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
sit down beside the panel here yeah I'm
still on Mike okay and I'm not think i'm
going to do is ask a question of each of
our panelists i'll just kind of start
them and and then what i want to do is
try to turn this over the audience as
soon as possible so i'm going to get it
started here you'll have a chance to
hear them answer a question each but I
please think of questions you would like
to pose to this panel and and give some
thought to it now so so Phil you know
it's in the Indus I've been in the
venture capital industry ten years and
I've heard this debate rage all ten
years as to whether there are more ideas
than capital or more capital than ideas
what are your thoughts about that and as
you go back the last two years in the
recession and you saw capital become you
know in short supply what are your
thoughts about where we're going from
here sounds great before I answer a
question I have two quick comments 1
about CMU
and what about race and she brought up
approval first I'm just excited to be
here you know Carnegie Mellon for me was
a huge inflection point in my life you
know I came to Carnegie Mellon as a
snotty-nosed kid who didn't know what he
wanted to do in his life and I graduated
as a snotty-nosed kid who didn't know
what he wanted to do with his life but I
knew a lot about programming and so that
carried me for the rest of my life and
with Ray you know it's funny I approval
was my first deal so it was when the
first deals i invested in and we were a
company in the compliance area in
kleiner perkins ray lane invests in
versa and proceeded to just kick our
butts really was being very kind early
we were very competitive in the
marketplace they did a deal with SI p
and just really sold it for 450 million
i think and i tell you you need that in
the venture world because it shows you
that you really have to get big or go
home which kind of carry that vision
kind of carried through the rest of the
deals I've done so thank you now to your
question I think that's a it's a
fundamental question in DC this notion
of too much capital versus too little
capital and I think when you look at the
first decade of the 21st century I think
what you'll see if you look at the
venture world it was it was defined by
too much capital in the marketplace and
you know there are a number of
implications to that you know in each
sector that's attractive you see too
many companies getting financed the
valuations associated with these
companies goes way up and so that leads
to you know poor returns in the industry
and I think if you look at our industry
in that first decade they were poor you
know talking about the recession it was
very interesting for our firm you know
there's two components to that it's your
existing portfolio and then you have
your new investments in on our existing
portfolio we really looked at triage you
know we really looked at our portfolio
we SAT around his partners tried to
determine which were the strongest which
would survive really focused on those
deals and really encourage the CEOs of
those companies to cut back to the basic
essentials and we as a firm look to
reserve capital so we had enough cash
to support these companies through the
long winter that we saw over the 18
months or two years of the recession on
the New Deal side in contrast we start
to lean in because we believe that
recessions are the best time to invest
you know there's a lot of talent that's
available the entrepreneurs you see the
quality goes way up because the people
who start businesses and recessions tend
to be very serious and very experienced
entrepreneurs valuations are more
attractive and specifically when you
look at this recession and Ray talked
about this a little bit in his opening
remarks there's a tremendous amount of
opportunity right now you have mobility
have clean tech you have cloud computing
and a number of other really interesting
mega trends that create significant
opportunities so we continue to invest
in the recession we're still doing quite
a few deals now and so we believe that's
the best time to invest slowly just
moved down the row here so Eric you're
you're leading a quite innovative new
technology you've got to be you know
have a technology background be focused
on your technology we focused on the
market be a manager be a leader and open
up horizons for a whole new market so
new energy is kind of where computer
science was 50 years ago as I mentioned
so how do you balance all this together
how do you essentially take electricity
or any other company you care to map
against from where it is today to being
the future you know an Amazon an IBM you
know a leader of its age yeah we should
sort of start off wireless electricity
is a little bit hard to get your head
around because we sort of learned our
whole lives that wire you know what
older City goes inside right you know so
I gone touch liar I mean all those sorts
of things and so I think to sort of if I
were given it in one sentence answer
sort of very simplistic but i think is
you know somewhat helpful particularly
when you're in something really brand
new
you got to figure out in something
that's very broad where you want to play
and then you have to build as much value
as you possibly can and that has so many
different dimensions to it that it gets
pretty complex very easily so I mean you
know ray mentioned a little bit about
the technology so it spun out of a
Carnegie Mellon competitor but we've got
a few Carnegie Mellon guys at the
company actually and but a professor
figured out how to transfer electric
power without wire now whether it's the
40 billion alkaline batteries that were
built in the world last year and then
thrown into landfill you know these tiny
little things these little double-a
batteries that we think are so innocent
when you add them up they add up to
something they're extremely expensive to
deliver power that way it's a great
opportunity if you can replace that go
to the other end of the power spectrum
you're talking about electric vehicles
you know we know that's going to be a
big business someday electric cars you
know it's a very tiny business today so
being able to start with something
that's very very very broad focus in on
the right opportunities to allow you to
build value over some reasonable period
of time and build value means at the end
of the day in sort of the crass
commercial world that we live in is you
know you want ultimately you know more
money coming in the door then goes out
so you know whether that's capital
efficiency try not to raise you know so
much investment capital that you could
never pay it back try to get things to
pay for themselves reasonably quickly
but at the same time allow you to grow
your business quickly it's how i
challenge the transitions from
early-stage engineers and scientists and
technology to to kind of a middle stage
2 amateur stage and our best-in-class
people what do you how do you do that
how you look for people also sort of a
non-trivial thing I'd started a company
actually back in the mid 80s where I was
one of three guys started the company I
ran it up to 150 million dollars so I
was there for each of the stages you
know raising money
in public you know ultimately we sold
out the private equity firm you know
20-something years later and this the
people that you need to attract will
vary at each stage of the business and
it was interesting a lot of the people i
started the business with at the
beginning or sort of you know it's the
old jack of all trades people who are so
essential at the early days and then you
get a little bit further on you get more
specialization in the business and you
need to attract people i tend to you
know looking people that i like to work
with I like to work with really smart
people and I'm sure that has something
to do with sort of the educational
background and those sorts of things so
you tend to want to work with really
really smart people and let them do as
much as they can to make you ultimately
look good and finding those people at
each stage of the business and getting
them to to contribute and get them
challenged and motivated you know as
part of the trick of growing the
business the business we're in right now
is you know it's you know physicists and
engineers I mean they're all PhDs and
they're very creative types and i have
to say of places and things that I've
done in my life you know including
having started my own thing this is the
most fun I've ever had you know and i
think you know we're talking a little
bit earlier you know you've had
experiences that have spanned the start
up to the extremely large companies you
know that phase of sort of the early
stage companies are quite quite
interesting i never thought i'd go back
to it again after running a large
company but found that there are very
enjoyable parts to them I know there's
anything more fun than running a
start-up it's it's actually my first
experience at it up just now at 62 doing
it for the first time here we go Pradeep
is you think about preparing students
preparing graduates that Eric will hire
what what how do you teach the min of a
shin do you teach innovation or is it
born ah I think it's part of both so let
me just talk about the education system
in the country first so I think
Jerry said it and nobody could have said
it better that nobody does it better
than Carnegie Mellon when it comes to
really developing an engineer or a
computer scientist who's going to hit
the ground running and we here at time
and time again from just about every
employer who comes to Carnegie Mellon
and as a citizen of this country who
understands there's other universities
in this country the populations about
350 million I wish there were more
universities that were doing it at least
as well or semi well like Carnegie
Mellon so let's talk about teaching
innovation I think we don't try to teach
innovation per se as a topical area but
what we do we do try to do is encourage
inquisitiveness questioning the basics
open-ended problem-solving at doing this
in the context of not one course or two
courses or three courses but it is what
we call innovation across the curriculum
where all of these properties are in
some combination or the other embedded
in just about every course so if you
went through Carnegie Mellon or a
four-year period some people take five
others take three I was thinking about
PhD is not undergrad you will find that
by the time you are through our
curriculum you have exercised so many
facets of your mental faculties and off
your thinking process that you are a
more complete person and what comes out
at the other end is a person who is able
to think holistically and you talked
about and Jerry talked about a net Frank
art but the epp being in college of
engineering and I think that's a
hallmark where policy technology
economics all combined together in four
years of BS in electrical engineering or
a computer engineering or mechanical
engineering has the same exposure so
what you see is similarity amongst
people and they come out in terms of the
innovative capability in terms of their
ability to deploy innovation even though
their domains might be like mechanical
or civil
or chemical or even electrical
engineering so Priya ed mentioned the
superiority of our educational system
our university level system but I would
take that one step further and that's
our research universities the top-tier
research universities are obviously the
finest in the world and have maintained
their attention to science prior to know
before the entrepreneur comes the
science and and maintain that research
and the focus on the long-term changes
that can be made recently a lot of
pressure is starting to come in now the
marketing the economics the dollar
starts speaking and and and it starts to
get some of the the basic science now
interested in commercialization do you
see that that stress in the system and
how is it affecting our basic research a
great question before I answer that I
want to go back to I Berg for one minute
so as Ray described it right this is the
mobile app that let's use that pictures
of potholes and whatever else and send
it straight to the city that's your
complaint right so one of the top most
complaints last year people went to PNC
Park and with snapping pictures of the
Pittsburgh Pirates so you know true
story so so let's get into nice question
like sir sorry I just had to keep Radha
so so let's go back to race question
right so I think one of the things that
we do really really well with our
students is we don't just experiment
with things in the lab we like to take
things out in the real world break
things learn from breaking things get up
on our feet and break them again and
learn again and that's what we're really
really really good at I want to tell you
the story of IANS cam which he mentioned
right so Ian scam was something that was
born out of my love for sports only
after I moved to Pittsburgh true story
never had watched the hockey game or a
football game until I moved to
Pittsburgh first weekend that I was
there watch
football games fell in love with the
game watch the hockey game fell in love
with the game started getting crappy
nosebleed seats at games tall guy would
stand up in front of me cut off my view
of the goal that ticked me off so we
started thinking how can we solve this
went to a bunch of undergraduate
students and said we've got to be able
to solve this is the real pain point for
me and guess what the students come up
with the idea of being able to do
large-scale Wi-Fi based mobile streaming
inside venues and when I say large scale
and parking 20,000 60,000 hundred
thousand people inside the stadium I'm
not talking about doing a little lab
experiment with five little thoughts I'm
talking about being twenty thousand
that's what our students do this is
really interesting house innovation
starts with a personal agenda yeah
really very intervention does exactly it
does i mean i think if you believe in it
and if you believe that if you build it
you would bite yourself then it becomes
personal to you but to take the example
of our students they went out there out
there they actually work most of these
games they built this thing from scratch
and we're the only wants to have it and
it couldn't have been done if we just
sat in the lab so going back to the
research point i think we like to think
big we like to go out and try things in
the real world and out of that comes
real research and that goes back to
health physicists and empirical
scientists used to do it in the 1617
others think about Galileo right he
tried to drop something out of the Tower
of Pisa not a little lab we try to do
things like that and I think that's
what's research about at CMU that's
great so ray can I add that yeah I think
underlying what we are saying is this
culture this lack of or enablement of
faculty or lack of oversight of
curriculum to the extent where people
like Priya cannot innovate cannot
experiment both with pedagogy and the
technology and that permeates at the
department level of the college level of
the university level and it comes to the
top to the bottom and bottom to top so
is it if you The Economist this finds
innovation is having value you know if
you innovate something it must have
value to a market what
the real source of innovation is it just
is it people with exploring minds is it
is it teaching is it a process is it you
know how does innovation really come
about Priya started it with saying well
we have an approach at Carnegie Mellon
which brings in the practical you know
that we we wanted we want to make
something and break it and see if it's
has value it's really what you're saying
what do you think it is it does it start
with the student to start with the
people to start with the mind or does it
start at the other end that we can
actually foster that we can actually
foster innovation with a cauldron of
Education anybody so um I'd like to
address that a little bit with our
curriculum so we have these capstone
courses right so which are you know in
most universities but I think one of the
interesting things there is you give
students a bunch of constraints you say
here's a budget here's all I will buy
for you here all the things you have and
out of that they come up with
extraordinary things that you look at
that and you know you weren't attempt as
intelligent as they were at their age
because the Apollo 13 test yes that's a
no okay gene test two from a venture
perspective you know I think we see it
as coming from people you know Oracle
wouldn't be Oracle without Larry Ellison
Apple wouldn't be Apple without steve
jobs and we did quite a bit in the seed
stage and what when did Frank good Frank
and the ipad wouldn't be the ipad but
not in break but you know we seed quite
a few deals and you know there are
certain people who just see the world
slightly differently than other people
and those people the people that go on
to change the world so i think it comes
from those individuals sudden so I'm
gonna say sort of you know people first
but I think you can help people along I
wish I'd had Priya by the way to defend
me when we got caught dropping water
balloons out of eat our morwen gardens
because measuring gravity uh huh yeah
right yeah I'm sure you are tennis balls
down the hallway and we were clocking
their terminal velocity I'd have joined
in
but but I do think that the educational
process plays a huge part in getting
people to sort of exercise their minds
so I mean it has to cut you mean it's
not you know going to just come from
education per se but it is a it is a
combination I think from my perspective
you know people saying its people it's
an easy answer because the world's about
people the world is about people we live
for people we die for people it goes on
or not I think it's not just people it
is the combinatorics of the team it is
what specialties what areas what's the
combination of personalities and how do
you put it all together and that is the
reason some people are great managers
others are not some people are great
leaders others are not because I think
there is a class of people who is able
to look through this who is able to put
teams together motivate teams understand
value propositions understand problems
right so that's really an important
concept at least to me and I'm neither
an economist nor a business person but I
can play both on TV very easily so the
other thing is I don't think innovation
I think innovation can start from an
idea that goes to fruition and I think
Internet is exactly an example of an
idea that somebody had and basically
back when I was dorp on it and it became
the internet after about 20 years and
talking to you Ray battery technologies
and energy is from the other side where
it's clear what the economics are and
you're going to drive technology to
satisfy those economics because without
that there was no market it's like two
different extremes and both are
extremely innovative both create markets
both create industries and both create
jobs and wealth in the country in the
world the you think about innovation and
and the complexity and Carnegie Mellon
University where you have best-in-class
in each of the colleges and then it gets
pulled together into new ideas how do
you think the world thinks of Carnegie
Mellon today do they think of us as
innovative as innovative as MIT or as
creative as Stanford do you think I
think everybody in this room believes we
are
more so is it the difference in the way
we innovate that would rank us is the
number one in innovation or is it
actually the number of innovations I
mean I Twitter to me isn't I'm sorry
else I don't see it as an innovation
yeah it course a lot of people use it
okay but what is it that will
distinguish us or is distinguishing us
in the academic world on how innovations
actually get implemented and i think the
word in my mind I think the world does
think of us as a very innovative place I
think all of these five six hundred
people out here who are all our alumni
and parents think of us as a very
innovative place but I think our problem
if there is any hypothetically speaking
maybe that we are too conservative in
going out and bragging about how
innovative you are so Jerry talk about
the Carnegie plan that plan
revolutionized education in the world
not just the US and even today we have
not gone out of her way or even then
till today we don't quite brag about it
as much so I think what we need to think
about is we need to start becoming
innovative in talking up and taking
pride in what we have accomplished and
what we plan to accomplish and what we
will accomplish in the future and you
know so I'm going to turn to the
audience go ahead if anybody is anything
i just want add one more thing so I
think the not bragging thing goes very
much along the lines of Pittsburgh right
you know in Pittsburgh we typically
don't brag about a whole lot we've had
free Wi-Fi in the airport forever their
airports you go into that you pay for it
and they'll have bigger banners right so
I think it's the typical nature of that
going back to pradeep's point I think
the other thing we do encourage our
students to do in the curriculum is to
take risk the embrace risk and to be
candid about failure and I think those
three things are very very big things
and they do shape our students and they
do make them open to possibilities
there's a question here there's a
microphone right behind you and maybe
there's somebody already at the
microphone
I've been working a department homeland
security and is the microphone on I
can't go ahead shout your name and oh
yeah well I've been working with mike de
Lange I've been working the department
homeland security and it's a short
history i get the same a veteran but uh
so I've kind of a was a I'm went to the
decision sigh and so EPP minor and then
go into the high school I come in here
and I didn't actually want to brief off
the comment about Twitter of how like a
lot of there's a lot of stigma to new
things right and if we kind of kept that
stigma I mean the internet would just be
a porn portal and same for like VHS and
like you know that don't don't blame the
content on the technology right and the
resi like going on because and I work
now in a emergency communications so now
we're seeing Twitter as ok there's
trending analysis of events happening in
real time right and then how do we get
them to tell us as the government and
people who need to respond and public
safety officials to rather than sending
videos to the media or rather sending
things because they'll go to them first
and then I'm and I was at my last
project was like oh general Homeland
Security Review and we had a national
dialogue on it and we had to approach
the public in the stakeholders and we
had this big thing and God knows it was
a fight for paper reduction act and
privacy and I had the Obama
administration was a year too late for
the open government directive and all
these things there's a stigma and for
all of us there's we all look at
innovation in technology but as we
there's naivete as we graduate and to
see that you know it's so probably only
one or whatever your ten percent is
innovation technology ninety percent is
a government and process as a guy who
has him in the government and seeing it
it has it's the great ideas they mostly
fail because they can't happen not
because they're not great ideas so I'm
curious how is if there is a way or
suggest that a working process of a
young professional to realize that as
much as in a we take for granted that
innovation is accepted and wanted and so
is there any way to instill out in
students or is it kind of just the path
that we should expect them to realize as
they graduate and you're not going to
change the world or not too quickly then
you should you have to work for it
get there can't get the dream job you
can't get the opportunity but you can
get there with your foot in the door
with you know the heart is in the
working obviously so we'd like to take
that one actually I can cut it I think
basically you have answered your
question you you have to innovate
innovation the way it is used right now
it's all about we think about innovation
as creating companies creating value and
so on and so forth if you think about
your life and four years of investment
as a student or five years or whatever
number of years you spend depending on
the program at Carnegie Mellon when you
leave you have to take what you have
learned and innovate around it to find a
place for yourself and become successful
in the world and that is one way to look
at Carnegie Mellon education where most
if not all of our alumni actually
understand how to create the value how
to extract that value of that education
applied to the good of society and to
their own family and themselves and
innovate around it to have a very
successful career so I think you
answered your question that's what you
have to do you have to not look at
anybody else it's just interesting
because we've all I mean I've
interviewed people coming out of
graduate school and stuff like that and
like I just I mean I'm not too far out
but like you look at them they really
think I'm not sure if we should have for
them but they really think they can
change the world and part of me is like
so you can work on getting your own
people Kate just what kind of different
philosophy may be looking back I think
it goes back to comment about basic
research basic research good research
has focused on a long-term change and
what impact it can actually bring
entrepreneurs there's many more
entrepreneurs and entrepreneurs start
thinking about an idea that they may not
have taken it through as Eric said
through the hundred fifty million dollar
stage in others what do they have to do
with this idea to make it a reality i
I've invested in two vehicle companies
electric vehicle but there's about 40 of
them that literally entrepreneurs have
believe they're going to create a new
car company out there and you just know
that's not going to happen so haven't
thought through what they have to do to
take this innovation
to the market all the way through to the
market and that's more than just the
invention a lot of good ideas okay okay
so Jerry's question is that the Obama
administration is trying to develop a
national innovation strategy does that
excite me or excite us or scare us now
we've talked about it a lot and it
excites us because we've seen the
opposite okay we've seen we've seen a
country with a 1 billion dollar research
budget and it's not pretty and so
innovation has to be encouraged that
there's just very little that can be
done today I know when I talk to
entrepreneurs in the mid part of the
decade and you ask them you know there's
a lot of money sitting in the government
the government wants us to innovate they
don't they want us to do more do you
know change things especially in energy
mostly entrepreneur's would say half the
government in my business no way a
little thing called a recession changed
all that okay the government's you know
printing money and so it brings them and
I think that's been a very good thing
because now entrepreneurs have opened up
to that and found out that there's
actually and now with the new
administration there's actually a real
receptivity to innovation in this
country as you as you know well and
Carnegie Mellon knows well arfa and
DARPA whirring we're so important to to
the revenue the research program at
Carnegie Mellon University and and and
and and we need those equivalents today
and that's what I hope the national
innovation strategy leads to is is more
artists and DARPA's the equivalent today
that then allows the research to be
funded which creates then the
entrepreneurs and the new businesses of
tomorrow that is the way the US will
grow anybody else I agree there are
certain problems that private capital
can't solve and so you talked a little
bit about that with clean energy and
having an administration that is focused
on innovation allows for funding for
some of these initiatives you know some
is the early stage rd like you're saying
with arp and DARPA some are such as the
cleantech one of your car companies that
received a significant grant from from
grant or loan I'm not sure which was
from the federal government that capital
is not being provided by private sector
because those type of initiatives just
are larger than what private capital can
provide and so I think it's critical to
have a president and administration has
focused on that issue you know you know
just as a being the entrepreneur who
always was sort of scared government's
run the new business and so I'm running
the company now where if you sort of go
back you would just asked me to get you
know it came from government sponsored
research I mean ultimately some of it
came through the military originally in
the you know that might be sort of scary
in some way but you start thinking about
it there are all kinds of mechanisms in
place we spent a fair amount of time
going for one of those are PE deals got
all the way to the finals and didn't get
it the guys were kind of bummed out that
came back to us a couple months later it
so we want you to do it again you know
sort of reapply you know that we're
trying to decide once bitten twice shy
or whatever because you only have so
many cycles but the fact is suggesting
that you know I actually believe that
most things have had a pretty strong
government influence in them if you
actually go back and analyze it and look
there and doesn't suggesting that things
are just sort of pure and come from oh
gosh you know I would say in venture
capitals regard to the energy industry
the government is our biggest partner
now there's I can't think of another
venture capital firm or private equity
fund that would be a larger partner than
the government and that has to do with
economics but it has to start with the
innovation that they want to see and so
and then there are many things as pillow
said like the national grid that no
private sector entity can fund you know
to build the long-distance transmission
lines or two to do some of the things
that we will build required if these
technologies come to fruition got a long
line here so let's yeah go ahead evening
Mike evening my name is Kevin join mekhi
class of nineteen eighty nine also a
loyal Scott so
it's it's interesting to me today that
we're in Washington DC having a
conversation about innovation given the
conversation in the financial services
sector on Capitol Hill and I'm curious
as to your thoughts on innovation with
respect to ethics and what role that
plays in in innovation hmm that's
interesting you know if I went to my
ethics department saying I'm innovating
ethics they might let me meet I know can
you ask an easier question so let me try
so one of the things again I'm going to
go back and talk about things that I'm
familiar with right so going back to our
embedded systems capstone design class
right so we're required to teach ethics
there and if you teach ethics the
driveway they listen to you they come in
they check in their attendance and they
walk out the door the way you teach them
that is you talk about whistleblowing
cases you talk about what that person
agonized through and then you actually
ask them to confess a failure they've
had in the last 15 weeks of the semester
they have to stand up and say this is
where I messed up and I messed up badly
in front of all of their peers I think
that's that's really useful it's
enlightening that it's actually embraced
but not curriculum lets us do that
there's also some pretty interesting
technologies that are helping this as
well such as the wisdom of crowd types
of technologies so a CEO that wants to
basically understand you know real
forecast so if they go out and they say
they're going to do something in the
market or develop a product they think
the market may need they can get a
wisdom of crowds viewpoint as to whether
they are doing what the market really
wants so there's actually some
technological breakthroughs and as well
next hi my name is David Miller 2001
msit grad I went back to Carnegie Mellon
for graduate school with the hope of
graduating and
being involved with startups and working
in an innovative space since I've
graduated I've had the opportunity to be
involved in two startups and my question
and both herbs have been in the wireless
space my question to the panel is what
advice would you give to folks like
myself who have had some experience in
the real world with startups to plug
back into the University and collaborate
with professors and current students and
so on to share our experience with the
university so there are multiple ways to
do that I don't are you based in DC or a
bit so there are multiple ways to do
that so for example in Silicon Valley
where we have a campus we routinely
involve people are alums with your type
of experience to come and create not
only role models for our students in the
program msit being one of them but also
to teach them about what they learn you
babying the individual learn from their
life experiences we routinely do the
same thing in Pittsburgh campus to and
engineering does it computer science
does it Hines does it where we have
various seminar series where we involve
our alumni to talk about their
experiences but that would be the easy
way of doing it the next step would be
to get involved with if you have passion
for some technology or some problem that
you're trying to solve to talk to some
of us and get involved with faculty our
sponsor a project in an undergraduate
class sponsor a project and a graduate
class like Prius class or any other
class and that would get you engaged and
involved and hopefully reinvigorated
visa V Carnegie Mellon and the
technology area give me your card let's
get you to class hahaha let me come over
to the side thank you I'm Lou Mittleman
math and English class of 67 I want to
offer a little love note to my education
at Carnegie and suggest what it is that
you do and
have done to inspire innovation years
ago somebody asked Isaac Asimov where he
got his crazy ideas and azimoff took
this correctly as a compliment and said
he'd never thought about that but he
liked to think and so he thought about
that and wrote a little essay called
those crazy ideas where he decided that
what he needed for his crazy ideas were
five things knowledge intelligence
intuition courage and luck knowledge is
owning a number of bits things which are
the case intelligence is the ability to
combine bits without necessarily knowing
too much about them intuition is the
ability to leap over mountains of
information and land lightly on the
wrong side courage while leadership
comes from an indo-european root meaning
to go forth and die which makes sense
because the leader is out front and
we'll get shot at first so you have to
have courage and then luck fine web
course pastor said luck favors the
prepared mind but not everybody has
these five things altogether Asimov did
but it's a terrific recipe for making a
task force or a group that's supposed to
come up with a good solution and I had
that in my classes at Carnegie that's
what my teachers did they called upon
these five qualities they encouraged us
to take risks to go out on a limb and
indeed to fall as you said priya but we
always fell on soft ground thank you
thank you for that
come back over here my name's Derek
Lowen I'm apparently a temper alumni
from 91 um I'd like to rip off the
cleantech and the other government
funding questions that have been coming
out and actually flip it a little bit
and ask you for your to reflect on a
concept on the concept that the funding
or the promise of an abundance of
funding from the government is actually
clouding the space in that it's
supporting idea is that while maybe
they're innovative are not in the long
run viable or scalable I don't think
it's I don't think it's true because
whether it is it depends on a lot of
these energy grants obviously come from
the Department of Energy and and they do
a rigorous technical review before they
do a credit review so ultimately they're
they're offering credit if it's a loan
ARPA is doing grants so they're they're
making grants of technologies and they
I'm sure a number that maybe shouldn't
have gotten through you know Eric should
have been approved on the first one we
actually on the board of a Carnegie
Mellon company that we found in in
research in CIT that we created a
company out of that got an hour for
grant arpa-e grant and and we happen to
think it was deserving but we have a lot
of companies our portfolio that didn't
that we thought were deserving so in sum
that we thought weren't some will creep
through but I think there is a rigorous
review process that some will escape
that will somehow get through and maybe
shouldn't have but the process is long
it's involved whether it's a loan a loan
guarantee or it's a Lords of grant and
and it often gets confused with stimulus
money a lot of the money is not stimulus
money it is actually money coming from
budgeted dollars research dollars or
or laws that were created many years ago
so some of this money that's going to
car companies was created back in the
bush administration 2007 to make our
fleet more fuel-efficient we have the
least fuel-efficient fleet in the world
including China worse than China and and
so it was we need to do to improve our
technology so I think for the most part
I think that I think we're getting it
eighty percent right everybody as good
as an ax to grind to say well why didn't
you pick my technology but I think a lot
of it gets through I had I was at the
DOA today had this very conversation
they encouraged us we had a we had an
application that was rejected and I want
to reapply because I think that we can
improve on some of the items they
rejected and they encouraged us to
reapply but you have to come back with
good answers on what we rejected and and
and don't be afraid to do it and do it
aggressively because the world thinks we
have thousands of companies standing
outside waiting for money it is not we
get the ones that just are undeserving
out of here quickly make a quick
decision that they'll never then just
let it give them hard notes that they
can't reapply then we have a bunch that
we get through in about six or eight
months and that's very few and then we
have this middle that we keep telling go
back and improve improve improve so now
I look I am I'm a lifelong Republican
I'm not a big fan of big governments and
and I I think they're doing it right now
I think I think they're mostly get
arrived and seen bad calls yet yeah real
bad calls I did want to just punctuate
that a little bit so I did say we didn't
get it but I read the analysis that they
did you know that the I was quite
impressed actually I thought weird they
get you know the people that actually
did this work he had a lot of consent is
a lot of outsider it was really well
informed it wasn't sort of you know it
was well done and I think there was a
level of diligence add to it so I'm not
sure there's a lot of mo it's not it I
don't see it as a big gift leave me I'd
be on the tea party bus if it work you
know
because I know I don't believe in
government giveaways but i think i think
this that's not what this is about its
back to jerrys question is that there's
an administration that recognizes that
innovation must be fueled we must be and
that the government can't do it and so
if the government encourages private
sector do it then do it with a carrot
and stick approach okay so we have the
money you know we'll give it to the
companies we think are most innovative
one thing that I've observed since
leaving Carnegie is that the evolution
of us human beings is slow but thanks to
Carnegie the evolution of robots has
been very fast now I would like to
provide x2 to converge no I would like
to suggest that on the basis of cost
safety and information to be learned it
would be better to send a robot to Mars
rather than sending a human being if you
agree do you agree with that hypothesis
and if you do why don't some of you
innovators come and sell that to
Washington actually that's happening
already right so if you look at the
government policy now they're going away
from manned space flights in fact the
Space Shuttle is going to be
discontinued and all main space flights
are gone and they're focusing mainly on
unmanned space flights so there is a
project in Carnegie Mellon right now
going for government funding to put a
robot on Mars happening right now the
news talks about Obama's announcement
he's going to put a human being on Mars
in 10 years or whatever but it could
happen 10 years don't sit okay next
question real quick Brian crew guy I
work in the energy industry and
government involvement in energy can
take many numerous forms that can be
cash grants their tax policy there are
loan guarantees which forms of
government involvement in the energy
industry and innovation in general do
you think are most effective and got to
get away from government picking winners
and losers laying the private market do
it as much as possible you know it's
it's interesting the government has
always been an energy so the government
is an intricate part of the
energy business and always has been
right from the land that's going to be
drilled or the land it's going to be
used all the way through the production
of the energy it's not a new thing that
department of energy just all of a
sudden says I'm we've got some money
that we're going to pick innovation but
but I do agree with your point of view
that at the end of the day because
they're offering a lot of funding and
they may determine winners and losers
through that that but that's that's not
their primary primary innovation I think
or involvement is is the economics but
they are involved in every aspect it
this is not a new thing it's been a
hundred years that they've been involved
in energy and they need to be they need
to be yeah every aspect of it yeah i
agree i think the other way to think
about it is what would happen if they
weren't and i think if they weren't a
lot of these promising technologies
would not survive and so it's very
there's a gap right now in late-stage
funding for a lot of these very
interesting cleantech technologies and
if there was nothing there that a lot of
that industry would go away because
there's just there's no money and so i
think right now although they do by
definition pick winners and losers it
does allow for some of this innovation
to flourish that has raised significant
capital today so i think it's
interesting because you know even though
my VC firm is based in DC I am NOT a fan
of federal involvement in markets but
you know when you look at it there are
certain investments and you know early
stage research you know that the
government federal government has been
in for years where the ROI is just not
there for financial investors and you
need some other entity to fill that gap
and so I think the clean tech market
right now is one example of that but
there are a number of others yeah okay
twenty seconds question how about a 20
second question Hank Myrnin 65
electrical engineering and temper 67 I
work in healthcare and to me the biggest
challenge facing unites
today as medical quality cost management
if we try to improve quality without
regard to resources it will fail if we
try to lower costs without regard to
quality it will fail if you were to set
up a medical center of excellence in
medical quality cost management at
carnegie mellon you would have three of
the four ingredients you would have the
information technology which is key
you'd have the economic know how which
is key you would have the behavioral
science which is key what you wouldn't
have is medicine and the question is
have you ever considered partnering with
the university of pittsburgh medical
center to create a world-class center of
excellence to face this number one
problem in our society it's a great idea
it's Jerry you want to answer this one I
think it's a I mean because it's it is a
great idea it is something that I think
a lot of folks at carnegie mellon have
are thinking about tonight pradeep you
just had a conversation already about in
fact Pete or 11 healthcare technology
the CTO of VA whose CTO ba and we just
talked about healthcare technology and
healthcare IT ok and the relationship
with the University of Pittsburgh for
that reason has developed very very well
I know in the lane center of
computational biology we involved
University of Pittsburgh a lot so that
so all the scenes are there to do it
it's a great idea you may have just
given birth to the next when i pea
center for you or the architecture on
that great are you got am I in trouble
um I'm okay okay boss says I'm okay okay
you know we you're not keeping your end
of the bargain here 20 seconds go all
right I'm Kevin Frederick's from CIT
2000 103 question I had is given that
we're in DC and youth there's been a lot
of talk on energy there is also a big
issue with what some people call it an
indie problem where there are solutions
the business is ready to fund wants
permits but there are local
constituencies that prevent a technology
from being implemented in examples Cape
Wayne
there may be others are their
perspectives from EPP and groups like
that that can help understand what it
takes to get some of these larger
programs off the ground that are facing
a regulatory roadblock so we have been
very active in that area so for example
carbon sequestration is in that class of
technologies where people are nervous
about somebody drilling holes under
their houses and storing tons and tons
and tons of carbon dioxide or liquid
carbon dioxide under the ground EPP and
chemical engineering believe it or not
have not really done a really
sophisticated analysis of the geology
and how gases permeate through rocks and
what is the leakage probability over
five ten fifteen thousand years but
Granger Morgan from EPP has been going
around the hill and talking about this
analysis sensitizing are lawmakers and
we in the college and also as carnegie
mellon have a Washington speaker series
where we pick a topic like that and have
a whole evening devoted to a
conversation on that topic so there was
a lot going on we understand the
regulatory issues that's what ray was
talking about in terms of policy being
intricately tied to technology at least
nowadays in many areas so thank you for
the question it's a very real issue just
drive through silicon valley right
hotbed of innovation try to make a cell
phone call you'll drop it six times
because nobody wants a cell tower and
there you know in in Menlo Park and
Atherton and Woodside okay hi any
seconds is our deal right erin
fitzgerald CIT 2002 and so with the
stimulus came a windfall for basic
researchers because there was suddenly a
lot of money or push to innovate and
fund basic research that could create
innovations for the future but with that
comes metrics and trying to analyze what
are the best investments to go into and
of course we have venture capitalists
here and economic impact is one impact
but i'm curious what the panel thinks
about what is the most undervalued or
underappreciated output of innovation
investment in basic research and beyond
and how do you think we could sell basic
research funding better I think the most
underappreciated investment of basic
research is personnel development at the
end of the day without that there is no
innovation there's none of this stuff
and somehow when a proposal is reviewed
your reviewed for the results you would
create and sometimes even when the
results are mediocre the fact that for
PhDs and for masters and five
undergraduates work on the project and
came out of it as a much bigger impact
on the result and I think that's what we
should be pushing that's what the
universities are good at we are a
research university not because you're
competing with IBM to control pads but
because we are producing students like
all of us out here like all of you who
go and make IBM's and Google's and
Kleiner Perkins and know that riddles of
the world's up